jean messia pour vous c'est une mauvaise
idée le retour de karim benzema alors
mon opinion et vous livre les sticks en
parlant des mondes opinion sur les
talents footballistiques de karim
benzema que je reconnais volontiers
c'est un très grand joueur
ouais il à marie leila recordman de buts
c'est moi je n'ai pas de problème avec
ça techniquement quand j'ai vu certaines
de ces actions c'est magnifique c'est
pas du tout là dessus que josé intérêts
n'est pas exactement mais ce qui me gêne
si vous voulez c'est que là on est en
train de parler de l'équipe de france
alors l'équipe de france c'est pas
simplement comment dirais-je une équipe
de football
on est dans la représentation il
représente la france à l'étranger il
représente la france en europe
c'est quelque chose l'équipe de france
est une des rares institutions dans
laquelle tout le monde se reconnaît
encore quelles que soient les origines
sociales professionnelles ethnique et
donc je veux qu'il y ait dans l'équipe
de france des gens qui incarnent la
france
or excusez moi mais quand karim benzema
en 2006 nous dit que son pays c'est
l'algérie nous dit qu'il veut pas jouer
qu'il aurait volontiers joué en algérie
mais que sportivement
comprenez pour une histoire d'argent il
préfère jouer en france lorsque il ne
chante pas la marseillaise lorsque il
crache par terre après la marseillaise
jouée en l'honneur des morts du bataclan
mois ces choses là me choque ça n'enlève
rien à ses talents mais je dis que ces
choses là me choquera une dernière chose
quel pays au monde à commencer
d'ailleurs par son pays d'origine c'est
à dire l'algérie accepterait dans son
équipe nationale un joueur qui ne chante
pas son hymne national ou qui crache par
terre après l'hymne national je crois
que les algériens et ils ont raison sont
très nationalistes très patriote et il
n'accepterait pas dans l'équipe
nationale
un joueur qui fait un tel affront à
l'hymne et au drapeau du pays je ne vois
pas pourquoi la france devrait
effectivement céder à cela
daniel riolo alors il ya trois points
dans ce que vous dites monsieur mais si
l affaire du crachat c'est un fake avait
rennes mais c'est l'autriche qui avait
dit non parce que c'est de là bas
pour le foot je veux bien accepter mais
bon bref c'est un fake
la déclaration à laquelle vous faites
allusion sur en gros des propos que
tiennent tous les binationaux c'est
quelque chose que vous entendrez chez à
peu près tout le monde moi aussi à
l'époque les propos m'avaient un petit
peu interpellé mais finalement quand on
se renseigne récemment abdou diallo qui
d'un joueur du paris saint germain qui a
fait toutes ses classes avec les
sélections en équipe de france a
finalement opté pour son pays enfin le
pays d'origine de ses parents le sénégal
les binationaux sont tous déchirée par
deux délits si les gens choisissent mais
sur le faire mais on a le droit en fait
des mais c'est comme tous les
binationaux voulions on peut aimer deux
pays oui mais il aurait très bien des
mois si oui j'en ai marre de ce
raisonnement qui consiste à dire que
pour que pour aimer l'autre il faut
commencer par se détester soi même qui
des deux va si on peut aimer les deux je
suis d'accord avec vous mais on n'est
pas obligé si vous voulez d'être dans la
provocation vis-à-vis enfin excusez moi
mais karim benzema qui l'a fait roi
c'est quand même la france oui donc on
lui doit au moins à défaut d'allégeance
il le doit au moins un million de récré
de france et en équipe de france si
c'est toujours bien bien quoi n'ont
jusqu'ici saint paul alors conservé
garder yahoo film à faire si vous sert
dans une équipe nationale dans l'équipe
tricolore il vous est pas foutu de
chanter l'hymne du pays que vous
représentez ici vous savez là ton alors
si on enlève les joueurs qui ne sont pas
les années de national non mais attends
mais plusieurs c'est le ballon mais
plusieurs erreurs font pas une vérité un
plusieurs erreurs font pas une vérité et
d'autre mais les autres ne chante pas
que lui
georges est le premier si vous mélangez
plein de dossiers alors il y en a qui
sont faits on essaye non
après vous arrivez à marseille je crois
même pas que ça soit fait calme de la
marseillaise c'est que ça peut nous
prendre toute une soirée
si on a pas dans ce pays plus
globalement éduquer même à l'école les
gens à savoir ce qu'est la marseillaise
c'est bien de la chanter c'est vrai on
va pas aller reprocher un joueur de foot
non mais vous pouvez pas ne pas la
chanter aussi ça chagrine
ça me chagrine que ce soit plus fait
dans d'autres pays ont perçu en france
mais si on n'explique pas à l'école et
si on abandonne depuis 30 ans maintenant
bout ce qui est relatif à la nation et à
la clinique ce que vos partis
extrémistes
un vrai problème suivant mais c'est un
autre débat matériaux concerne pas que
karim benzema je vais vous dire c'est
quoi ça vous avez parfaitement raison ce
que de tout ce que vous avez dit j'en
arriverai pas une virgule vous avez
parfaitement raison à et maintenant est
ce qu on institutionnalise cette
capitulation non bio type en mettant
absent cinq équipes de france le
résultat de sa non wes qu'au contraire
on écrase et un peu l'équipe de rognons
réserve l'équipe de france a de vrais
patriotes quelques problèmes et qu'ils
en parlent